escondieron la cabeza así tildó la
magistrada sonia sotomayor el actuar de
una mayoría de jueces de la corte
suprema de eeuu el máximo tribunal
rechazó el pedido de emergencia de los
proveedores de servicio de aborto que
buscaba frenar la ley de texas que
impide acabar con el embarazo después de
la sexta semana
la orden de la corte es asombrosa ante
una solicitud para prohibir una ley
flagrantemente inconstitucional diseñada
para que las mujeres no puedan ejercer
sus derechos constitucionales y evadir
el escrutinio judicial la mayoría de los
jueces han optado por esconder la cabeza
bajo la arena
anoche la corté silenciosamente asintió
la promulgación estatal de una ley que
incumple con casi 50 años de precedentes
federales el presidente de la corte el
conservador john roberts se sumó a los
liberales para los cuatro votos a favor
del bloqueo sin embargo fueron cinco los
votos en contra
la normativa de texas para muchos pone
en peligro el derecho al aborto
estipulado en el famoso presidente del
caso roe versus wade en 1973 ésta
prohíbe el aborto desde cuando se
detecta el pulso del feto es decir cerca
de las 6 semanas cuando en muchos casos
las mujeres ni siquiera saben que están
en embarazo incluso en casos de incesto
violación y abre la puerta para que
ciudadanos del común demanden a quienes
ayuden a una mujer a abortar
en este momento estoy aquí realmente
para estar con mi comunidad de mujeres
para tratar de hacer una diferencia y
mostrarle al gobierno que no estamos de
acuerdo que estamos furiosas y que no
queremos que esto pase
aunque no es una decisión basada en la
constitucionalidad de la ley texano el
pronunciamiento de la corte suprema-
refleja el impacto de la hera trump en
la rama judicial de eeuu el ex
presidente nombró a tres jueces ultra
conservadores durante su mandato en la
ahora líder de la casa blanca- joe biden
afirmó que la resolución de la corte
suprema es una violación sin precedentes
a los derechos constitucionales de las
mujeres